elle a été baptisée talent et quoi pour
les chercheurs mais on la connaît
surtout sous son nom de code j 35 une
mère et polar dans le comportement
encore inexpliquées avait fait le tour
du monde en juillet 2018 talent et coire
refusé d'abandonner son enfant mort dont
la carcasse couler elle avait
littéralement poussé étrenné son
baleineau décédé peu de temps après les
naissances sur plus de 1500 km jour
après jour les images de ce voyage
surtout dans les eaux canadiennes avait
ému le monde entier
c'est par des images de drones que les
chercheurs se sont aperçus que tu allais
quoi était de nouveau enceinte et elle
n'est pas seule
la plupart des femelles de son groupe le
jeep ode vont aussi donner naissance le
problème c'est que les baleineaux ont
juste une chance sur deux de survivre
jusqu'à leur premier anniversaire
conséquence du manque de nourriture
jusqu'à 69 % des femelles font des
fausses couches parce qu'elles ne
mangent pas assez régulièrement dit elle
les épaulards se nourrissent surtout de
saumons qui n'a une denrée rare dans les
eaux du pacifique où ses polars vivent
ce sont des épaulards sédentaires qui
écument une zone située non loin de la
côte à cheval entre le canada et les
états unis
[Applaudissements]
là même où les images de talent et quoi
et son baleineau avaient frappé
l'opinion publique china en 17 jours j
35 a fait davantage pour faire connaître
cette population que notre recherche en
35 ans explique-t-elle
les 72 et polar de ce groupe
emblématique sont maintenant sous haute
surveillance
le fédéral vient d'ailleurs de réactiver
une zone d'interdiction de pêche sur la
côte ouest de l'île de vancouver pour
tenter de réapprovisionner le
garde-manger c est faux l'art ici bonne
offert à dîner à le canada vancouver